let's follow along with this story um
a man named sam johnson who happens to
live here in nashville
has become the latest victim of a cancel
culture mob
that according to the left doesn't exist
we just heard from levar burton doesn't
exist it's consequence culture
but canceled culture certainly seems
real to the people whose lives are
destroyed by it people like sam johnson
now johnson is the ceo of a company
called visual
was the ceo i should say as the media
tells it he became the subject of
national outrage and backlash and was
fired from his job
and had his life summarily ripped apart
because he was caught on camera
allegedly engaged in the quote
homophobic harassment of two gay
teenagers one of whom was wearing a prom
dress
now in the story the only one we've been
told the one that everyone of course
automatically assumes is totally true
and not in need of any additional
context at all
in that story johnson is the bad guy the
only bad guy
and given that he's homophobic quote
unquote there is no consequence too
harsh for him
the video of this supposed harassment
went viral yesterday
um johnson's name was trending
nationwide
the left was calling for his head
accounts with millions of followers put
johnson's name and personal information
out there here's a tweet from kathy
griffin for example
this is what she tweeted with with a
with the video of of
of the incident she says if this is sam
johnson in nashville tennessee the ceo
of visual
healthcare tech growth strategist
married to and then she gives
his wife's name which i won't give where
they may reside in and then she gives
the town where he lives which i won't
give it seems like he's dying to be
online famous
so no problem there just a celebrity
with 2 million followers publishing a
guy's name
his wife's name and his town of
residence all because she's mad about a
video of a dispute
between him and two other people none of
whom she knows personally
of course many headlines and major news
publications followed
many of them matter-of-factly stating
that johnson homophobically harassed a
teen boy
it didn't take very long with this kind
of pressure for his company visual to
publicly condemn him and announce that
he'd been fired
i mean they didn't even wait a day it
just it took a couple hours
and uh they were done of course they
claimed that they investigated the
situation
only took them you know a few minutes to
do it but they investigated
okay well uh we'll play the infamous
video
but before we do that i want you to hear
how this incident
was framed by the guy who did the
filming
jacob geithman is his name he recorded
the altercation it was his boyfriend
who was wearing the prom dress so here's
geitman on tiktak
giving his version of events and i want
to play this first because
if you haven't seen the the video of the
incident itself
when you hear it being described a
certain
image will be in your head a certain
expectation
and then when we play the actual video i
want you to see whether
it lives up to your expectation so here
is geitmann
um in two short videos on tick tock
giving his side of the story here it is
so tick tock has now removed the video
of my boyfriend being harassed on our
prom night two times for harassment and
bullying but i'm still gonna give you
guys a story time and i'm gonna have my
friend bree post the main video on her
talk account which i'll comment below if
you guys wanna go and watch it this is a
long story probably gonna have to make
multiple parts but i'm in college my
boyfriend's a senior in high school and
he decided that he wanted to wear a
dress for his senior prom to kind of
break the stigma around men wearing
dresses he looked gorgeous
everybody loved it nobody had a problem
with it right we went to this hotel
close to where we lived and we got a lot
of good photos we were there for about
an hour and right as we were about to
leave we were standing outside in this
little middle area with a bunch of
buildings surrounding
us this man comes up stands about an
inch behind my boyfriend and he's like
what are you wearing
and he's like a dress why and he's like
well why are you wearing that you
shouldn't be wearing that he's like
because i can and i want to and i really
don't give what you think so this man
starts going on and on throwing insults
at him you look disgusting you look
ridiculous you look like an idiot men
shouldn't be wearing this all of this
homophobic banter
so i grabbed my phone to start to record
because i knew i wanted to record from
the get-go so i grabbed my phone started
to record he slaps my phone out of my
hand it goes flying over on the concrete
part two coming right now part two it
was getting hot in my car so i decided
to come inside
so he hits my phone out of my hand it
goes flying on the concrete i go to grab
it to start recording him again
and he tries to swing at me again which
you can see in the original video when
the camera goes out for a second you can
see him swinging
he tries to hit my phone out of my hand
again but he misses and he hits my
boyfriend in the back
so that's when all of the moms that were
there they're getting really involved
out there like you need to calm down
like this is absolutely ridiculous you
were out of your mind
and at this point the hotel staff had
gotten word from inside about what was
going on so two other ladies come out
and they're like okay guys what's going
on out here
he pretends like he has absolutely no
clue what's going on he's standing there
he's like i've just been standing here
the whole time
i don't know what's going on i didn't
try to talk to them i didn't hit him i
didn't try to smack his phone out of his
hand i'm like dude i have a minute long
video
of you harassing us you can't just
blatantly deny it like that
the staff was really great about
everything they sent him back to the bar
because he was
pretty obviously drunk just because they
were calling the police and they didn't
want him to freak out any more than he
already was
and as we were leaving they told us that
they were kicking them out and calling
the police so
okay now based on that
you have a certain expectation for the
video of the incident you're expecting
a drunken a pretty obviously drunken
that's what we're told probably
screaming
psychopath yelling homophobic slurs
that's how the altercation's been
described both by geitmann there in the
video and by the media
and by the cancel mob on twitter but
that's not
quite what you see when you watch it for
yourself so
here is what happened as documented uh
here it is
i told that i want to wear something
okay okay
is that right i think he looks gross
looks disgusting
yeah yeah you look like i look like
white
you look like an idiot away from me what
does he look like
look like a [ __ ] get away come on
please stop stop stop
i'm sorry i'm gorgeous are you yeah
yeah just georgia
really worth it okay so there you go um
now a few issues here first of all
this video as always picks up in the
middle of a confrontation between these
people
there's quite clearly something that
preceded it the guy filming
says that sam johnson instigated sam
johnson for his part gave a statement to
newsweek
saying that he initially went over to
ask the teens to quiet down because they
were being loud obnoxious and vulgar
uh and so this wasn't initially about
the dress it had nothing to do with them
being gay
he was going over because they were
being obnoxious and he was talking to
them about that
i don't know what really happened i
wasn't there but neither was anyone else
currently calling for sam johnson's head
on a platter
which which they got they got exactly
what they wanted as always
what i do know is that in that video
the only person screaming and cursing is
the guy in the dress
i also know that the guy filming is
prompting
sam johnson literally suggesting insults
for him to say did you notice that
do you think he's disgusting do you
think he's gross
that was his words the guy filming said
it
that seems like odd behavior for an
innocent person who's supposedly being
harassed
i mean i don't know i don't know about
you but uh i've never
i can't remember the last time i was
harassed but if i ever was i wouldn't
suggest
um insults for my harasser to say to me
i also know that sam johnson does not
appear drunk as was claimed he's
standing there hands in his pocket
smiling coily this is this is not the
demeanor and tone that you'd expect
based on how jacob guyman described his
behavior
i remember basically what he described
are you expecting a drunken shouting guy
shouting insults in fact the person
being harassed
in that video seems to me sam johnson's
the guy being harassed geitman is
following him around
camera in his face while the other guy
screams and curses
and homophobic the man does not say even
one
anti-gay thing in that video why is it
homophobic to say that a dude in a dress
looks ridiculous
tell me exactly i want someone to
explain to me exactly how that's
homophobic
he does look ridiculous after all yes
you look men in prom dresses look
ridiculous
it is objectively absurd for a guy to
wear a prom dress
the dress literally was made for girls
that's why it's made for girl body parts
you're not a girl you're wearing
something that doesn't fit you wasn't
made for you it looks silly
none of that's homophobic you can
disagree
it's a disagreement over style to call
it homophobic is to claim
that all gay people wear prom dresses or
like men who wear prom dresses
which to me seems like a rather
degrading and insulting assumption
indeed we're told by the boyfriend of
the dude in the dress
that he wore it not because he liked how
it looked but because he was trying to
make a statement
he was and when you're making a
statement you're calling attention to
yourself
he was looking to break the stigma well
if you wear something to make a
statement and call attention to yourself
you can't very well complain when you
get
exactly the attention you were hoping
for you know when the waiter brings out
that giant heaping portion of attention
you ordered
you can't get offended and send it back
to the kitchen
so we have to ask ourselves were these
two guys the victim of unprovoked
harassment from a drunken homophobic
bigot or where
or were they fishing for a reaction
literally trying to prompt a reaction
even verbally prompting one and then
ready to film it and ruin the life of
whoever takes the bait
which version of events seems most
reasonable and plausible to you
or was it something in between whatever
the case
what i can say is this this little petty
exchange between a guy named sam johnson
and a guy named jacob
geitman and a guy in a dress is not
national news
nothing that happened here whatever
provoked it whoever's at fault
whatever the context deserves to be in
the headlines
even pretending that johnson was fully
to blame let's just pretend that for a
moment
pretend that he was the sole bad guy in
the situation let's pretend that
everything happened exactly as it was
described
does he deserve to have his life
destroyed over that
does that warrant outrage from millions
nationwide
does his wife deserve to be named and
shamed publicly
does his family deserve to be doxxed and
harassed
i mean the answer from rational and
decent people
is no obviously not
but the soulless mindless bloodthirsty
hordes who make up the cancel mob
don't really have an answer they don't
think these things through
they have the brain power and
discernment of starving vultures
they simply swoop down upon any carcass
put before them to be consumed
and yesterday sam johnson was that
carcass
and for that they not sam johnson
are today canceled well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content